at our first film tonight star structure
Ronan as Mary Queen of Scots it opens
tonight and on Monday very about you
often
Edinburgh think it was the Edinburgh
Castle Edinburgh Castle yeah for the
premiere and oh Nicola was out she was
while she was there she is Laurie look
at her that she's got a slightly better
time than you and the drummer to be
honest will you just cut what are you
looking at I'm not I think I'm looking
at the drums and the eggs there was a
lot going on they gave us eggs to shake
like maracas and I've never felt more
out of tune but she was so into it she
was amazing and just like going up to
people and going hey has gone I'm Nicola
like like it was no big deal and she
really got into it she did the catering
as well she's got some marshmallows on
sticks you know this is the premise of
the film I mean we kind of know what
happens in the end
spoiler there's not very clear spots to
yeah but if it's you against Elizabeth
first played by Margot Robbie and I
didn't know any of this but in life they
never miss but I'm but in the movie
there is a meeting there's a meeting yet
we just sort of took the old artistic
license lied we just we just you know
you follow these two characters the
whole way through the film and hopefully
grow to sort of love them or at least
care about them and you're quite
attached to their story and it just felt
dramatically like it was the right thing
for them to finally meet so yeah so
Margot and I just have this one scene
together and we decided to stay apart
through our rehearsals and the shoots so
I didn't know what she was gonna look
like as Elizabeth and she didn't know
what I looked like as Mary and so when
we finally saw each other are we both
just kind of went good I've got like
very very emotional because we had been
kept apart for so long so this film up
see has you
it is Margot Robbie but it also has a
celebrity horse in it Prince now what
would he have seen Prince he and I think
we've got a picture of Princeton yeah
there is um he was Wonder Woman's horse
so he's working um yeah yeah you know
that horse
and he just and he just wouldn't he
wouldn't do and I picked him so it's my
own fault
it's just cuz he's so good-looking he's
such a good-looking Holmes you know I
mean I know he just wouldn't do anything
for me and so every time I was on him I
was like having to act quite queenly and
regal and I'd be like okay onwards and
Prince just wouldn't move me you'd be
like you know trotting away and he'd
just stand there and I'd be like onward
Prince you just wouldn't move and then
and then about halfway through the shoot
I realize that when they would call
rolling before we would do the take he
would get really nervous and he do have
you been there and he had like a nervous
cough that he would do so they'd say
rolling and I just hair it was from the
horse and I was like okay I know I know
the kitties he'll now that's amazing
that he knew yeah he knew what was
happening
so we could manipulate the situation to
work in my favor
[Music]